can you turn something a little
different here today before anyone goes
nuts by the way I'm not looking to make
this a regular video series uh when I
did my reaction video to my own trailer
for nostalgia critic Suicide Squad like
all the reactions were oh my god you can
finally show the reaction
videos they're on how they're so dumb
and pointless and stuff I was just like
I know idea there was like this backlash
of interest with you um but I mean I was
clearly a satire but I'm I'm really fine
with them they just kind of aren't my
thing but if you like doing him and like
watching butts like go ahead I mean that
that's totally fine um but but yeah that
was just me having a little bit of fun
but I wanted to do something particular
here because I saw a video that Brad the
Brad Jones did where he tried Oreo O's
now here's the thing uh and he does a
lot of these reaction videos they're a
lot of fun you should check him out uh
but I had these when they first came out
and this was way back in the late
mid-90s I think and it was awful and let
me say I want Oreos I am an Oreo holic
like to me Oreos are like just the
perfect cookie they are just the perfect
sweetened I've never not been in the
mood for an Oreo and it's like the
cookie equivalent of bacon you just put
it on anything and magically it makes it
delicious and makes it amazing it
becomes the great thing the road he just
put Oreo on it uh so I was really
shocked that the Oreos OHS the Oreo
cereal really blue uh the first time I
had it it tasted like I was eating the
box
I was just tasting little chunks of box
and it was terrible so now it's back uh
apparently it's super popular because I
literally got the last box they only
have it at Walmart and I got the last
one
and I guess it's just got this following
I suppose and they must know it cuz look
at the size of that thanks huge
oh we just sold like five more boxes if
he just made it the ring wasn't this is
like double the box size uh so yeah I
was going to try this and see if it
still tasted as awful um as I remember
it
or maybe it's different cause Brad was
saying that it tasted different tasted
better because he didn't like it either
he compared it to cat litter so I wanted
to try this but then while I was there I
also found this now this I also have
when it first came out except it wasn't
called Cinnabon it was called semi minis
and I remember this being one of the
best cereals I ever had I loved it I
thought was amazing but I haven't tried
it a long time in my taste buds have
kind of changed so now I'm really
curious what to think of these if we
have a cereal that was awful when it
came out but apparently is supposed to
be good now and a cereal that was
amazing I came out but might suck now I
don't know so just for fun just for
giggles and because Rob can do a real
thoughts this week because this is the
video I'm giving you and I like it I'm
not looking to make a regular thing out
of it it's more like I I was gonna try
these anyway and I just remember having
extreme reactions to both of them so I'm
just curious about has an extreme
reaction to it now so probably won't be
a regular thing unless you want to see
more of these um
I'm usually not a big reactor but these
are two things that I really have strong
feelings towards my first Hannam so so
there's a Wagyu I got my ball rare I got
my milk and everything so I'm going to
try this we're gonna try Oreo is this
look like more being awful oh okay
so just right off the bat as soon as I
open this this smells like Oreo if this
smells like what I wanted to smell when
I opened it like whatever 10 years ago
so this the smell is already on the
right track so we will we'll see what
comes with Gaza's box huge
holy smokes okay I got pretty small hole
just so you know I can try both cereals
I got my fake milk here I never know if
milks good evaporated
the milk my wife gets so I I have no
idea I have no idea what's supposed to
be good for you anymore I mean clearly
the this cereal is good it's super super
healthy for you so okay this is a tick
to is going to the second time I've ever
had the cereal Oreo O's maybe with a new
flavor or a new ingredient something I
don't know but here we go
okay okay that that's a lot better
that's definitely a lot better this um
okay so it's not as good as you know
still the initial idea is I'm because
this sounds like it should make itself
you know or you Owen it's a cookie that
already you need milk for to fully enjoy
so it should really can make itself but
this is much closer this is actually
pretty good you know what it is so yummy
weird comparison if you see my
commercials special I did this whole
thing on kicks and kids was the first
fight you have is amazing and then every
bite you have afterwards it gets less
and less to the point where it's
terrible this isn't terrible it does not
get to the point where it's terrible but
it does get to a point where it's like
okay this is just kind of average and
cereal but the first bite every first
bite you take is really good it's like
you're tasting a freshly dunk Oreo
cookie in milk and then it kind of turns
into tea you know who's like diet
version abhorrent oh it's like the ones
that have like less calories and fat and
stuff like that are not very good it
kind of tastes like you're having that
as you chew anymore oh my god that's so
weird
hey I could ride that first that first
bite all the way through but just gets
less and less and less but doesn't turn
awfully it does not turn awful it just
kind of gets you know man and you keep
chewing it but the first bite
any damn good if only I could play they
can master it somehow where all the
bytes were first bytes
I know it's a strange I never done this
before I've no idea if I'm doing a good
job that's the best criticism I can give
of it right now yeah Pam just that at
first bite every single time is actually
really good it tastes like how Oreo O's
should taste um you know what I just
want to I just want to get the box again
oh my god okay so much I love Oreos so
alright that that's what I think of Oreo
is good a good update definitely much
better than before it does not taste
like the Box anymore so that's really
really nice so uh okay
I'm going to cut here and I'm going to
show you what I think of the similar bun
one but after I finish this okay so that
was my take on Oreos I liked it I don't
know how to buy it again but I'm glad I
had it this time I'm glad I tried I'm
glad I gave it a no champ now we're
going to have a Cinnabon or descending
mini to resurgence - that's ok as
yourself smell more distinctly Cinnabon
than the cinnamon you said attendee mate
should kind of smell like typical
typical cinnamon rolls but this one you
can tell that has like that whatever
that frosting is a fun there it tastes
like that's definitely in there - so it
should be kind of interesting those are
the one I remember tasting amazing I
don't like it I'll be honest just even
idea where I'm coming from I don't like
to make cereals anymore used to be a
cereal holic but like if I got older
they kind of got less and less like my
taste buds change and stuff I you start
eating different food so the only ones I
absolutely love I still up the Mintos
crunch
I still love any kind of Captain Crunch
I'm all over I love and it can't get
especially Christmas crunch don't know
it gives me a box every year and then
all the other good ones now are kind of
like imports from Europe like crave I
remember why I saw was in Austria we
didn't have
yeah that's an amazing cereal it's awful
for you but it's a it's an amazing
cereal
we need lion bar cereal here in America
let's I mean I know it's not like a big
thing here right now the lion bar but we
need that serioga that was really good
cereal too and I know there there's
always like these blueberry ones usually
blueberry cereals are pretty good but
yeah that's about it
any other cereal like cocoa puffs or
cocoa pebbles or Lucky Charms I don't
get into them anymore like they're not
the worst they're just not sounds of
other words but like yeah I don't get
into many more so I'm curious to see
what I think it is but yes I like the
rose this I remember being really good I
marry kind of being like cinnamon toast
crunch it's like if since toast crunch
heya kind of like a little you know kind
of like a little scoop for more milk you
could like hold milk in the little you
know spoon side a bit yeah which just
made it even better so okay so this
I remember being good hopefully it still
is
okay now that's interesting that's in
trail
what's interesting don't apply it to
their bite I think it's a first I've
ever had this reaction because okay with
Oreos you try it first bite oh let's an
Oreo cookie and everybody gets less and
less and less and just tastes like a
generic cereal this one starts off
pretty good you say good bye bye okay
that's pretty good and then the more you
have it it actually tastes a little bit
more like a Cinnabon so that's kind of
interesting yeah it's so weird because
like okay it starts off okay yeah that's
pretty good and then it starts to fade a
little bit that kind of comes back at
the end I never had cereal do that
that's so weird
um it's I I'm getting a little bit more
of like the frosting taste out of it I
had maybe now I'm wondering if like
Cinnabon and cinnamon T's were connected
maybe Cinnabon destroyed city mini
skipper the competition I don't know see
if it tastes raw raw like this is good
okay definitely taste bear with the
mouth look but yeah okay this this is
still pretty decent the frosting taste
is a little overwhelming that was one
thing to say to me is I kind of liked it
was a little bit more simple it was kind
of like a thicker cinnamon toast crunch
honestly I like I said what that will
scoop in there but uh yeah this is
pretty good it is super sweet now to say
Oreos wasn't but this is like kind of a
punch in the tongue with sugar and again
I think that's kind of like the frosting
taste to it
yeah like the the first bite is kind of
like cinnamon toast crunch oh you're
just kind of eating almost like a softer
cinnamon toast crunch it get soggy
half-assed but some people like that but
yeah and then it gets into and that kind
of fades and then yeah that weird
Cinnabon taste I said upon frosting like
really really comes in there so so okay
that's if you really like Cinna
but did you leave their frosting you'll
probably like this sorry if I'm starting
to glow here I had to use the sunlight
for this and the automatic exposure
don't look crazy so I had to set it and
now it's coming out really really bright
nevertheless okay so that's that's two
of these cereals now that they're
actually kind of good
uh this one much better than before and
and this one is pretty decent okay so
it's two cereals out now they've come
back I don't know how is this one's been
back for a while or not but but they're
back and they're actually worth about
and this is coming from a guy that
doesn't really get that much into that
me cereals anymore I used to be a cereal
Halle used to love them all but yeah and
now I'm a little bit more picky so for a
guy that's a little bit more picky that
they're worth so we're definitely buying
one Cinnabon maybe Twyla this is pretty
good unless like I said it could be I
haven't fixed the whole bowl yet I get
peanuts my facial whole Bowl I'm just
going to be like oh my god like I have
diabetes after this like this is the way
too much sugar but but it's pretty good
for a few bites which is final you
should have in the morning anyway I
think it's obviously these are not the
pose for you so um yeah guys that's
about it we'll be back next week with
another real thoughts like I said just
going to get to it this week and this is
something you want to see let me know I
can do more um or if you're just like no
stop no more uh totally fine with that
too I'm just not huge into like doing
the reaction videos and stuff but but
maybe this is something people enjoy I
could do more if you want me to stop I
have no problem with that either this is
just something a little different I
figure if I was going to try it might as
well film it let you guys know what I
think as it's nice out tutorials and
that's that's fun to talk about too so
that's about it and hopefully I will see
you later
you